if you want to take a shahada and then
your journey will start
I've done the seven day free trial of
the qurani app and it exceeded All my
expectations alhamdulillah I was worried
that was an overrated product that's
what he fought until he tried it what
was the system you can build a habit
with the Quran by seven day free trial
promises no credit card details required
at all and you decide for yourself is it
overrated or is it underrated I'll put
the link in the description box below
button says there's Android and iOS the
link is there download it and see what
time it is
so we had a sister come
um you know with abroad
so come in so we had a discussion
privately because there were some
concerns that you had there were some
questions that you had
um so just tell us in a nutshell that
for example the first one that we
established was that you believe in
Allah you believe the prophet Muhammad
is the final messenger do you believe
the Quran is from Allah okay so you was
a Christian before
yes but I realized that I've never been
like a proper Christian like I don't go
church every day or I don't pray it
would only be for the special occasions
Christmas Easter things like that okay
all right this is okay this is
understandable Okay so you don't believe
Allah to be a man no you don't associate
partners with him okay so I will say to
you you're a Muslim so we had another
shahada just a minute yeah so the same
thing I said to him yeah you internally
already believe you have to testify it
on your tongue okay now before we go on
to that you know because that seems like
you're ready you had some questions what
is it that was stopping you you
mentioned a few things because there
might be sisters that are watching this
yeah the dress code okay and the hijab
okay
what's the issue with those that you
have that's is that what's stopping you
from taking a shower
is that and then hearing Muhammad
married a six-year-old okay and there's
the verse in the Quran I don't know what
verse it is but it doesn't specify that
a lady has to cover up her to her knees
or to be up below her legs it says the
private parts and then obviously your
bottom so I can understand that in a
different way okay so the thing is we
try to understand how the companions the
best of generations understand it yeah
um if I'm not mistaken the words come up
yeah okay so what that means is that for
example let me give an example
um some of the Arabs used to they used
to be you know they used to deal with
camels Etc some of the camels used to be
a certain color from the head down to
the neck now some of the arrows used to
look at the camels and say that look at
the camera
yeah meaning
they ascribed the headgear yeah to uh
they drive to the head for example if I
go and buy socks today or I give
somebody if I give you some socks you
won't take the socks and wear it as
gloves you won't put it on your head why
so it doesn't make sense because it
belongs in your feet so when we talk
about socks we know where the socks
belong so when Allah like for example
that word is used where the job is not
used in that sense yeah means cover yeah
no no but cover what how do we
understand it so the way we understand
it is that what we understand from the
first generation is that it is something
that belongs to your head and then Allah
says cover your bosomes so it's not just
a headpiece
you also have to have something wrong
which covers your muscles okay so
therefore yeah it obviously it has to
you have to cover so what we see is for
example because I actually done a video
about this couple of years ago there was
a woman a TED talk she was there and
she's like you know all the hijab
doesn't mean this and that this is my
confusion because it doesn't specify I
know who my means in I don't know in
Arabic language the word actually means
from your head to your muscles like the
the Garment that you're talking about is
the Garment that's talking about
so the government that you're talking
about is that the sister is obviously
she believes in Allah believes in the
message believes in the uh the Quran yes
but she was asking yeah so um
so I was just telling her that basically
in the Arabic language that when we talk
about Hamad it's actually referring to
the head and the bottoms it's something
that covers it yeah so she was saying
where is the evidence that because in
the Quran it doesn't mention the head
yes yeah okay uh basically sister
when we when God has revealed the Quran
has revealed the Quran as well along
with understanding of with the prophet
salallahu the way that how he explained
so when when the Quran was revealed so
in order for people not to misinterpret
the Quran in a way that they think so
that's why God has revealed the Sunnah
as well part of it which is kind of
explanation
which is kind of an explanation to the
Quran yeah so Allah has mentioned in the
Quran about for example what is the
jilba in the Bible is literally the
cover of the whole body yeah but the but
but the hands and the feet for example
that's the generally and Allah as well
has mission in the Quran
foreign
now Allah has said to the believer
Muslim which is for example a Christian
or Jews or or even even Pagan at the
time of the Prophet so I'm used to wear
him out all of them used to have
somebody used to cover their head but
Allah has specifically said to the
believer woman
to cover their chest this is the jebus
call it this is the this this side to
cover it as well so Allah says
like this so what about in today's like
Society we have different fashion I
could wear a turtleneck instead okay so
that's what he's saying for example the
Arab woman before in the pagans they
used to tie their headscarf in the back
said is that you cover your boss so not
only had because the cover in the head
they already done that that was already
already given yeah what Allah revealed
was that now you cover take what you're
doing undo it and cover your muscles
uncover this side exact cause of this
and the prophet saw Allah said that he
used to wear something called something
like that the Arabs used to wear
something like that and he is to do and
he was making he used to wipe over this
so it is something was done by men and
women something used to wear it like
this but women specifically called or
they were recommended to to cover this
side now that's why it is something
important when we understand Islam we
have to understand it in the holistic
way we take it Aslam as it is so some
people recently I will kill you maybe a
few things maybe you came across certain
people they say this only for to
distinguish between uh three women and
slave women at that time Etc and again
that's that's not that's not the case
firstly secondly as well some people
they say
uh you know that the the gym is anything
that's the part of the part of the body
not necessarily decide so it's okay for
women to uncover their food all of these
if they try to misinterpret Islam that's
why you'll find these all these millions
of Muslims who understood Islam exactly
how the prophet saws said and then only
some group of people they try to
misinterpret Islam the way that hey
that's not right so that's why sister
firstly then you become Muslim firstly
or nothing not yet but we was going to
come to that because she has some doubts
but the thing is just that he was
mentioned also that for example it seems
like you are obviously struggling when
it comes to the hijab okay I'm
struggling with a lot of things okay
that's fine look you need to understand
something yeah Islam for you to accept
Islam for example if you came and said
um I I might end up still wearing skirts
that doesn't nullify you with slime you
can do that again look if you came and
said Brother Ali I'm gonna take my
shahada but I'm going to take I want to
take my shahada once I start covering
fully because I'm wearing skirts now and
I'm gonna carry waiting for the next two
three years that doesn't stop from being
a Muslim you can be a Muslim and you can
obviously it's not permissible but
obviously we're telling you can have
those gradual steps to work towards that
I understand the whole concept why you
have to cover up because men they gaze I
understand that not necessarily because
Allah it's not this misconception some
people say that Allah told a woman to
cover up because men can't control
itself that's not it's not true Allah
says
meaning I don't care how you dress
you can be in a tent I have to know my
Gates regardless it's just that when I'm
doing my bit obviously the opposite
agenda is a fitness for me it'll be nice
if a woman's covered up at least my gaze
it's not harder for me to lower my gaze
so it's both parts doing the job so I
want to make that clip because some
people think that oh Muslim men are
animals so Allah Muslim women you cover
up because these for animals that's not
true we are told to lower our case
regardless I I've been speaking with
people and I've been not wanting to be a
hypocrite because I know one day I'm
going to wear something long the next I
might wear a knee length skirt sister
look look these are things look we do
think I'm not a sinner do you think that
we don't commit sins our sins are
different the point is this that doesn't
stop you from accepting Islam and it
doesn't nullify you Islam what would
take you out the fall of Islam or why
you can't be a Muslim is if you come to
him today and say I still believe Jesus
is the son of God I say okay let's work
on that because you can't be a Muslim
and believe that you don't believe that
sister you believe it's Oneness you
believe in the process you believe in
the final message you are you are a
Muslim internally you have to testify it
but these things that you're talking
about is a gradual process can I ask
something so what if um I take the
shahada yeah
and like I'm going through like I don't
want to dress that way I don't want to
okay which way hijab to hide my ankles
to hold my legs to hide my arms like I'm
Western this is I'm used to dressing a
certain way and I'm happy like that okay
can I say to you something
you missing a beautiful point you said
can I take my shahada but I can't do
this at this at this moment firstly
there is no harm for you can I still go
to Jannah even if I'm trying to say
you're going to go Hellfire let me tell
you something anyone anyone who lived
establishing the prayer fasting do what
you what you can do from there from the
Commandments of Allah now and as will
the the clothing is a gradual change
it's a gradual we don't say to you today
you have to wear the hijab we don't say
this but we say to you it is something
important as well for you to consider
within a time frame Whatever Whenever
you think is convenient for you today
what if I never do that even if you
never do you do it
but yes but we said to you but you need
to know as well that by you not doing it
there is sin yes let's make some things
clear
if you look Never Say Never number one I
have this one lesson I learned yeah
never say I will never do that you might
end up dressing better than born Muslims
mark my words this day write it down
when you have that connection with your
lord
sorry
I swear to the Lord sister that there
will come a day because and I want you
to buy a book by the way yeah it's
called Beauty sick
okay let me tell you something yeah you
know sister this um think that Allah
says look Muslim women do this by the
way they fall into this as well yeah
sister if you read the book the book is
talking about our sisters Muslim and
non-muslim who are under this pretense
this this thing which is rigged yeah the
reason if your sister like this you know
why because you have been absorbing the
dawah you know they give Tower people
think we only give Tower they're giving
Tower when you go in oxygen you see
Billboards and they watch a movie and
you go on your phone they are giving you
that what they are trying to make you
feel as if you are ugly you can't leave
the house without makeup you need to get
your lips this time that done the
question is this has been stuck in your
mind it's the time when you accept Islam
sister and you get close to Allah your
mind is going to purify that and you're
going to slowly slowly realize that when
it comes to Beauty sister yeah okay I
understand obviously you know a sister
sometimes they're made to feel ugly
because of the beauty industry all this
kind of stuff but my dear sister it's a
rigged system yeah if a man
if you want a man yeah a good man who
wants you want him to marry you Etc only
Allah can send you that what do sisters
think what does you know our hijabi
sisters you know what they do they think
I want I want to find somebody nobody
wants someone in a hijab so they said
let me take my hijab off make my hair
nice
all you've done is this committed a sin
because what Allah was going to write
for you was going to reach you
regardless
if you find yourself showing this and
that all it's going to do sister is get
you the wrong attention and it's going
to break you Allah doesn't care what you
look like on the outside it's irrelevant
now this doesn't mean that you become
you don't look after yourself sister
I'll get my haircut every week every
week I'll get my haircut no missing at
all but yes every week I know the thing
is the thing is this you can look for
your partner yeah but what I'm saying is
that these things are there because why
the opposite gender want to take your
clothes off because why because they
just want you eye candy so what I'm
saying is Sister once you've turned your
back to that and you realize because if
you think about it I know you're not
happy having to leave the house every
day with makeup I know you're not happy
wearing skirts like that I know the only
reason you're doing it yeah
and I said once I was giving down
and then two women they came revealed
they're shivering
and I said I said listen I was I was
telling them they said I mean I was
comfortable like this she said of course
not I said then why are you doing that
why are you doing yeah because why are
you doing it because I look good I said
you're gonna you're gonna get ill and so
especially in high heels you're not able
to because they take you off I put my
boots on today because they look nice
okay but sister bless you in front of
Allah you look nice with your Iman yeah
no boost nothing but what I'm saying is
again the bearing boots is not Haram the
point is this sister that this cycle is
rigged yeah you are never going to be
happy there are people when you read the
book in the book it says there are young
girls who are starving their self they
have a clock routine every four hours
they have one yogurt so they don't pass
out
what kind of freedom is this this is the
greatest oppression that has been put on
women yeah yeah so much so that the
society is telling you beautify yourself
do this and these men who are
approaching you you think they want you
for you sister wallahi Islam honors you
Islam says if a man is interested in you
he has to come and speak to your dad he
has to give you Maher he has to do
willima he has to provide for you why
because you to us as our sister are more
dear than all the diamonds all the gold
every wealth in this world that's what
Allah tells you that you are precious by
the way look if someone's forcing you
it seems like you believe it so if you
believe it you just have to testify you
know it's like look let me ask you a
question maybe relate to you what's your
favorite Foundation
which which brand
even though I don't know how to pray I
don't know anything and I'm still gonna
think because I'm still gonna dress how
I wanna listen listen to me yeah
look let me make it worse okay even we
will say to you obviously gradual step
look even if you said to me tomorrow I'm
gonna go and I'm going to do this and
this and I'm gonna look irrelevant you
being a Muslim is relevant to that all
you're doing is sinning okay we all do
but we'll try to improve also don't stay
in one place try your best to slowly
slowly improve and I've been reading I
loads merciful yes but he's also severe
in his punishment because I've been told
by so many people that if I'm not going
to change the way I dress I will not go
to Jannah no no
for the prophet Muhammad peace he said
that there were two men there were two
brothers if I'm not mistaken yeah one of
them used to transgress Allah's
legislation and laws and the other one
used to warn him and say to him Allah
stop doing this stop doing that he would
not listen one day the other brother
said to the other one you are never
going Jannah
he said to him you said you are never
going Jannah and you know what happened
after they died yeah both of them passed
away and on the day judgment Allah said
to the other one to do another one he
was sinning yeah he said to him go
Paradise so the one who was righteous
Pious the one he said to him you're not
going to heaven he sent him to the
Hellfire why now let's make some
clarifications this doesn't mean you go
openly sin the point is this nobody can
come and say something about Allah that
he himself hasn't decided I cannot come
and say you see that person is going
hell or Ali dawa is going Jannah nobody
can say that we see they don't Iman he
died on disbelief nobody can come and
see you you're going Hellfire yeah and
to me now Christianity just seems like a
huge like contradiction yeah a huge one
I like it is there's nothing if there
was something so strong to keep me I'd
stay but there's nothing social sister
you're on the hug yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna we're gonna have to I don't like
pushing anybody to shahada I'm very
specific I don't like this you know for
the sake of it you believe so I'm gonna
have to be a little Pusher here my dear
sister because I want the best for you
if you're my sister if feels my sister I
would do the same for because I care
about you okay trust me this is the work
of shaytan
okay so repeat after the chef inshallah
okay say after me